hypertext markup language or html is a
language that defines the structure of
content on a webpage development started
in 1989 at cern by tim berners-lee who
had just invented the world's first web
browser world wide web the origin of www
but he needed a publishing language to
display content within it so he chose a
syntax based on the standard generalized
markup language which uses opening and
closing tags to provide meaning to
otherwise unorganized text like h4
heading p for paragraph and most
importantly a for anchor to link to a
different web page the language
underwent many changes during the
initial rise of the internet and was
standardized as html5 in 2008 the
version we know and love today modern
html contains tags to handle a variety
of different media types like video
audio and canvas to draw custom graphics
on the fly the typical html element
starts with an opening and closing tag
in the middle we have content which
might be text or additional html
elements called children the opening tag
may also have one or more attributes
which are key value pairs that can
customize the appearance or behavior of
the element to build your first web page
create a file named index.html this file
contains a hierarchy of nodes based on
the document object model or dom a
webpage starts with an html tag and has
exactly two children a head and a body
the head contains things that aren't
directly shown in the webpage like a
title or a meta tag to give the page a
description but notice how the meta
element has no closing tag closing tags
are generally optional when an element
is fully self-contained the body
contains the actual ui for the end user
we might start with an h1 heading
followed by a paragraph of content to
add an image we use an image tag which
you'll notice is self-closing then
define the source attribute as the file
path to the image and you'll want to
give it an old description to make it
accessible to robots and screen readers
what makes web pages revolutionary
though is their ability to link to other
web pages on the information super
highway use an anchor tag to create a
link then define the href attributes as
the webpage that you want to navigate to
when clicked html also provides
structural tags like division or div
which are often used to group elements
together where they can be styled to
represent complex ui elements like
navbars when you're happy with your code
grab the full file path to the html file
and paste it into any web browser
congratulations you just built your
first website this has been hypertext
markup language in 100 seconds hit the
subscribe button so you don't miss the
upcoming sequels thanks for watching and
i will see you in the next one